for example next oh I'm power W
referendum the executive director the
Howard Jeeper foundation coming up in
Davos we've got some questions here this
one of it answers how can there be
sustainable growth when will resource
depletion vemos imminent this is from
atlas here over youtube you know it's a
very fair question and when you think
about some of our most natural resources
of three basic ones come to mind around
around water and around hair and a lot
of what we focused on through our work
project has been restored component
because it's almost always left out of
the dialogue and when you think about
the global carrying capacity for human
population it's going to be driven by a
by all three of those for sure but
definitely by how much food we think ur
gifts and so part of what we've been
endeavouring with philanthropic Lee has
benefited how can we influence farmers
particularly large scale producers in
the United States to shift a lot of
their production or more conservation
waste resources resource farming so that
soil quality inherently can be preserved
revision built over time so hopefully
that will be initiated gains more
traction in the coming years